Muslims back to back to back to back to
back are coming up here. They're in the
midst in their lives. They're in the
midst of a transition. They're coming
out of Islam. They're realizing and
waking up to the falsehood of Islam,
experiencing Jesus. Jesus is coming to
them and making himself known. The same
thing can happen to each and every one
of you. All you have to do is open your
heart. I dare I dare you to try it. Call
on him one time. He will not forsake you
just like he didn't forsake these
brothers. I was I was sleeping on a park
bench for the first day and I call out
to Allah. I'm like, "Where are you? If
you're if you're real, how come I have
to sit on this bench and sleep in the
cold?" Mind you, it was like about - 20
and nothing happens. I keep calling out
to him. There's nothing that happens.
Then at the back of my mind, I
remembered, you know, there I have a lot
of Christian friends. They pray to
Jesus. They say they that he answers
prayers. So I pray to Jesus and would
you know it. A couple of Christian
homeless shelter dudes find me and take
me to the homeless shelter.
So I go there and I read the Bible. I
had some time to read it. All I read was
John. That's it. Because I always heard
my one friend, his name is Johan, always
talking about John. Right. Yeah. I read
it and truly it's one of the most
beautiful books I've ever read. Mhm.
It's like, how can this God come down
here with us and experience what we
experience? Why would God ever do that?
Right. Right. And I'm just sitting I'm
just sitting in the corner. Everybody's
like, you know, eating and stuff and I'm
just sobbing. Right. I'm I'm I'm raised
and born in an Islamic family and um
actually a tough one. And um what I saw
for myself and what I see from the
friends and from the area where I live
and where the people who the people are
um it's always all about hate it's all
about anger you know what I mean and
it's it is not was not fulfilling and
when I started to look for God and was
starting to look to someone who can yeah
save me and the interesting part is I
was I had a I had a dream and this is
actually amazing. I had a dream of
Jesus. Wow. Yeah. And um it was really
shocking shocking dream. I I was in a
sorry for my bad English again. I was in
like a let's say in a dark hole and and
he was like there and he was reaching
for me. He was like Hakan come out you
know come out and just follow me. And I
would say Jesus is the way. I love him.
I really came up on here to ask you a
question. Right. That's right. What do
you want to ask me? I've had I'm only 17
years old, right? I'm still pretty
young, but I've had some experiences and
I've It's really hard to talk about, but
growing up, I I grew up in a really
strict Muslim household, right? Mhm. And
it's just things that I've been taught
are not always what the reality is when
I'm reading when I'm reading the Quran,
right? I was told that uh Muhammad has
perfect morals, Allah has perfect
morals. It's just everything's perfect,
right? Yeah. So I learned I learned uh
literary Arabic which is a like the
speaking Arabic and the Arabic of the
Quran are two different things, right?
And I learned it and I read the Quran
and I see these absolutely horrible
things like the treatment of captive
women and the the
the waiting period of the the
preubescent girls which implies that
you've had intercourse with them. Yep.
So it's like I can't agree with it no
longer. Yeah. And so eventually one day
I stopped praying to Allah. And
obviously I was I was like 16 at the
time. And so my dad he started getting
angry about that. Oh he noticed you
stopped praying and oh wow. And I'm
bipolar as well, right? So I have I have
really dramatic mood swings and one day
he was pressing me about it and I got
really angry. So he kicked me out of the
house. Uh I was I was on the street for
maybe 3 days. He kicked you out of the
house because you stopped praying. Yeah.
I didn't even renounce Islam or
anything. I was just confused, you know.
M and I I brought it up I brought up the
subject many times. It's just they don't
want to talk about it. It's just
Muhammad's too perfect for us to even
question it. Right. Yeah. And so I was I
was sleeping on a park bench for the
first day and I call out to Allah. I'm
like, "Where are you?" You know, if
you're if you're real, how come I have
to sit on this bench and sleep in the
cold? M mind you, it was like about
minus 20. I live in Edmonton. It's
pretty cold here. Edmonton, Canada. And
I was I didn't have any jackets. I
didn't have anything. I just got thrown
out the house, right? And nothing
happens. I keep calling out to him.
There's nothing that happens. Then at
the back of my mind, I remembered, you
know, there I have a lot of Christian
friends. They pray to Jesus. They say
they that he answers prayers. So, I
prayed to Jesus and would you know it, a
couple of Christian homeless shelter
dudes find me and take me to the
homeless shelter.
So, I go there and I read the Bible. I
had some time to read it. All I read was
John. That's it. Because I always heard
my one friend, his name is Johan, always
talking about John, right? Yeah. I read
it and truly it's one of the most
beautiful books I've ever read. Mhm.
It's like, how can this God come down
here with us and experience what we
experience? Why would God ever do that?
Right. Right. And I'm just sitting I'm
just sitting in the corner. Everybody's
like, you know, eating and stuff and I'm
just sobbing. Right. While I'm reading
this, I don't know, man. I don't like I
want to believe in Jesus, but the thing
is it's going to cost me everything. It
depends on what you mean by everything.
Obviously, I'll have my well, what he
promised, right? Eternal life. I'll lose
my family and gain lose my friends, I
guess. So, the thing is this and this is
what uh I know it's but what you're what
you're dealing with is real. It's you're
you're it's real, man. You're you're
still in your parents household today?
Yeah. I'm about to go to university,
though. Okay. What you're dealing with
is real.
I'm glad that you came up here because
there's a lot of people who um they
don't understand what it is to be a
Muslim who discovers Jesus. They don't
know. They don't know what the weight
that that brings for to be a Muslim in a
Muslim household and you found you find
Jesus. The pressure of community, the
pressure of family, losing the family,
losing friends, losing the community
that you're familiar with is a heavy
heavy toll on any person, any any
person. We got to be real about that.
Yeah. It's easy for me to just say, you
know, well, Jesus is going to, you know,
he pro obviously promises you a
different family, a new family in faith,
a stronger one. And I I can say these
things, but we're we're humans, guys. We
still feel we love our our friends. We
love our mom and our dad. We love our
uncles and grandparents. We love the
people we grew up with at the masjid and
around. We we love these people, right?
We have a genuine connection with them.
It's hard. It's the hardest thing to do
to turn away from that, to let that go.
It's hard. We got to be we got to deal
with the reality of this. But the thing
is, right, while I was reading John, you
can call me crazy if you want. other
people have. But the thing is, I felt
something filling my chest. I I honestly
have no clue how to describe it other
than that. Yeah. It's like there was an
emptiness I didn't even know was there.
Yep. And it just feels like something
filled me. Like something else that like
a person filled me. Yeah. You can like I
know it sounds crazy to other Muslims
like in here. It's like what what is
this guy talking about? It doesn't sound
crazy to believers though because we
know who and what that is. That's the
Holy Spirit. That's the Holy Spirit.
Jesus says that those who believe and
hear out of their hearts will flow
rivers of living water, which is the
Holy Spirit coming inside you to convict
you of your sin, to convict you of your
life and turn you to Christ and give you
this realization of go of God's glory.
It's the Holy Spirit. And so all you
have to do is I know it's easier said
than done, but all you have to do is say
yes. Say yes. God has shown it's up to
you. He's answered you. He's pulling on
you, tugging on you. And this is what
Jesus says. He says that my sheep hear
my voice and I know them and they follow
me. He says that. And you being 17 years
old, having your experiences, you heard
his voice and you know it's him. All you
got to do is follow. Now, how do I say
yes, though? With your with your heart
and with your mouth, you tell him. You
repent to him. Lord, I'm sorry that I've
ever doubted you. I'm sorry that I
didn't believe in you, but now I
believe. Talk to him from your heart.
Whatever you whatever's on your mind in
a confession mode. You confess how you
feel. Confess your sin. Confess how you
disbelieved and that you now believe.
confess that you believe him and you
take him as your Lord and you are
trusting in him not only for your
eternal salvation but also for your
sustenance your provision here in this
life that you trust him and that you put
all your weight on him and you bring
your troubles to him and you're giving
it all over to him. You trust in him say
yes you are my Lord. I believe you died
for my sins. I believe you rose again on
the third day and I believe in you and
trust in you alone. That's how you say
yes. Okay, man. Has to come from your
heart. It was nice talking to you, you
know. Of course. Of course. I'm here
anytime, man. You can message me or if
you want to come here and if you want to
confess, you can do it anytime. Anytime
you want want to do it on your own time,
in your alone time, do that. And um I'm
here for you if you if you need me, bro.
Okay. Do you want to do it now or you
want to do it later? Let's do it now,
man. I can't I can't like this up. Yeah,
for sure. I'll just ask you that. I'll
just ask you. Do you believe that Christ
is your Lord? I do. And do you believe
that Christ died for your sins? I do.
And do you believe that it is him alone
that you trust in for the salvation of
your soul? If I don't trust him, I can't
trust anyone. So, that's right. Yes.
Amen. With that being said, there's a
getting your microphone. Did you Did you
do some Did you take headphones out or
something? There's I'm not sure, man. I
don't know what's happening. Don't worry
about it. Don't worry about it. It's
just a distraction. But with this
confession, this is what the Bible says.
Confess with your mouth that Jesus is
Lord. Believe in your heart that God
raised him from the dead. The Bible says
this, you will be saved. You are saved.
So because of your confession, bro, and
you believe in this in your heart today.
Today, you are saved. You've done it.
You are now a brother in Christ. You are
now among the children of God. And you
have another family. You have an entire
family, thousands, millions of believers
all over the place. Okay. Thank you,
man. No, thank the Lord, brother. Thank
the Lord. It's all Christ. He's He's
pulled on you, man. And he's pulled on
you for a reason. For a reason. And
you're only 17 years old. Yeah. You're
only 17 years old. So, be encouraged,
man. Be encouraged today. Do not fret.
Do not be in fear. Do not be in shame
amongst your family members. Be
encouraged and take hold on tight to the
Lord. Hold on tight to him. Do not let
go, bro. Do not let go. No matter what.
No matter what comes. Don't let go of
Jesus. Don't do it. I won't. I'll try my
best. Good. Here's another thing is your
next step. Your next step is to get
baptized. Okay. In fact, Jesus says when
he was sending out his disciples, he
told them, "Go and make disciples of all
nations, baptizing them in the name of
the Father, Son, and Holy Spirit." So,
it's a command from our Lord to for us
to get baptized, representing us dying
with Christ and being raised alive with
him again, washing our sins away. So,
um, are you could you said you're
connected with Christian friends? I have
I have quite a few actually. Yeah. Good.
Good. So, uh, go go to church with them.
I don't know if you've already been
doing that, but you know, go to church
with them. Never been to church before.
You never been to church before? No.
Dude, you're going to make them excited.
They're going to be so excited. Go to
church with them. Try to get in contact
with the with the pastor or the priest
there and tell them what happened. Tell
them that you used to be a Muslim and
you recently became a believer and
you're looking to get baptized. You
know, I feel so like crazy right now.
It's it's it's it's unexplainable, isn't
it? Like like two years ago, I would
have called myself crazy. How could you
even consider that Jesus is God? Yeah.
Unless you've experienced him like you
did two years ago, you would like,
"Yeah, no, that's crazy." But then
you're sitting there on the bench and
the only one who answers is the true and
living God. And he reveals himself,
Jesus Christ. He's true and he's alive,
bro. Yep. He's alive and he saved you,
man. He saved you for this moment. Woo!
Wow, that's crazy, man. Glory to God,
man. Glory to God. Do you have a Bible
with you? I know you're in your parents
house, but do you have a Bible? I do,
actually. I have uh this international
version. I don't know what version it
is. I think it's all good. Good. All
right. That that's that's awesome. Read.
So, hold tight to the Bible. Um have you
you said you was reading John. Have you
did you get to finish reading John or
did you get to I finished the whole
Bible. I really Yeah. Oh, shoot. I read
Jonas like when I came back home I I had
to read the rest of it. Yeah. Oh, that's
awesome, man. Well, keep it up, man.
Keep reading it because the B this is
what the Bible says. Um and and this is
actually you know it's I've held it
close to my heart. It says it asked this
question. How does a young man remain
pure in this world with everything going
around us? How do we remain pure and
steadfast? This is Psalm chapter 119.
It's a long chapter. I think the longest
chapter in the Bible. But this verse
says, it answers this question. It says,
"By meditating on the word of God, by
studying his word, meditating on it day
and night, every day, seeping yourself,
digging deep into the word of God,
staying close with him in that intimacy
cuz that's how he talks to us. We talk
to him through prayer and he speaks to
us through his word, right? Through his
scripture and also through his holy
spirit like how you've been hearing
him." And um so make sure you do not let
go and you study that word. You study
the scriptures like no other.
Absolutely. Okay. If you need anything,
if you need anything, email me. My my
email is in my description. Message me,
tell me who you are and we can get in
contact, you know, possibly tra exchange
numbers so that I'm always here. You can
reach out to me, man, if you have
questions or, you know, anything. Okay.
All right. Thank you so much for having
me here. No, thank you for coming, man.
Thank you for coming and having the
courage to tell the Lord. Yes. Thank
you, bro. And I thank God for you. All
right. You have a nice day then. You
too, brother. You, too. Bye. Peace,
guys. Guys, guys, it's beautiful.
Beautiful. Hakan, how you doing? Hey,
mate. Um, uh, awesome that I reached to
you. I wasn't expecting that. Um, first
of all, sorry for my bad English. I'm
from Germany, Turkish roots. And yeah um
actually it was amazing to listen to the
brother who convert to yeah let's say
Christianity and you're a Christian
actually not um actually I tell myself
for the person who is looking right now
and um it is actually pretty amazing.
I'm I'm right now really confused a
little bit. So confused that I can tell
that I'm not a Muslim anymore. So I'm
not in Islam. I left it. It was actually
not that a hard decision for me because
well when you look at it with your heart
you know when you when you start looking
when you start searching you see there
yeah point discrepances which makes no
sense for me and um and that's why I was
like okay I'm going to leave that and
I'm I'm I'm raised and born in an
Islamic family and um actually a tough
one and um what I saw for myself and
what I see from the friends and from the
area where I live and where the people
are the holy people
um it's always all about hate. It's all
about anger, you know what I mean? And
it's it is not was not fulfilling. And
that's kind of what which um which
formed me a little bit too. So um sadly
well um the interesting interesting part
is um when I started to look for God and
was starting to look to someone who can
yeah save me and the interesting part is
I was I had a I had a dream and this is
actually amazing. I had a dream of
Jesus. Wow. Yeah. And um it was really
shocking shocking dream. I I was in a
sorry for my bad English again. I wasn't
like a let's say in a dark hole and and
he was like there and he was reaching
for me. He was like Hakan come out you
know come out and just follow me. And
what I did in that in that in that time
it was like about a year ago um is like
to start thinking about it to start
looking around. And I do I do have um
let's say I would say Jesus is the way
and I love him. I think it's it's
amazing person. I I think I do
understand the trinity the trinity. I do
understand that. I think this is this is
correct. So I accept accept Jesus as
God. So that's that's that's fine for
me. But I don't know brother. I don't
know what I'm missing that I can't tell
that or that I can say, "Hey, Jesus is
my Lord and it's my way and I just want
to say it, but I still can't. I don't
know what is missing." What? Yeah,
that's what I That's what I would ask. I
would ask if you don't know what it is.
Um, you know, cuz you you said that you
you you believe you love Jesus. You
believe he's the way. You believe that
he's God. you you know you you affirm
the trinity the father son and holy
spirit existing the same one god
infinitely you just it's hard for you to
just say yes at this point it's it's
hard for you to say yes what do you what
would you guess it is do you think maybe
you still is it is it a tie to maybe
your family and culture do you a fear is
it what do you think it is yeah
um to have to understand me I'm I'm I'm
a rebellious person was always in my
I don't so I don't I don't care about
the decision of my family to be honest
to you. So I'm married, I have a son, I
do my I go my way and it's everything is
fine. I I I think what is missing is
that yeah Islam corrupted me a lot and
maybe it's the way of uh to understand
as Jesus as God I do understand but the
trinity too but the Holy Spirit for
example this complexity of 3 to one or
one to three it sometimes confuses me um
why why does it need to be complicated I
was looking at it I was reading it I do
understand the words and I do once
understand the concept but still I have
some yeah question marks in my head and
I don't get rid of it and it actually
makes me a little bit crazy so I I have
holidays right now I'm like really
reading and reading and looking and I'm
a really big fan of you as David Wood
and a personal prophet actually kind of
same background he is from Turkish
family in Germany me too so I got at his
I was looking and I saw Jesus
But I still I don't know what's missing
and that's why I maybe reach to you and
I want to talk to you. Maybe you or your
the community my brothers and sisters
what kind of what can I do? What is
this? What is this what I'm I'm missing?
Well, this is what I would would would
say. Um because it sounds like it sounds
like you believe you believe already,
but you have also just a a level of
unbelief there as well, which is
perfectly fine because let me show you
something man. Of course, just I'm going
just share this this text with you and
let me just where my Bible at here. Here
we got Mark chapter 9. We're going to
read down a little bit. Jesus heals a
boy from an unclean spirit. So watch
this. So when the disciples came when
I'm sorry, when they came to the
disciples, they saw a great crowd around
them and scribes arguing with them. And
immediately all the crowd when they saw
him were greatly amazed and ran up to
him and greeted him. And he asked them,
"What are you arguing with about with
them?" And someone from the crowd
answered, "Teacher, I brought my son to
you, for he has a spirit that makes him
mute, and whenever it seizes him, it
throws him down. He foams and grinds his
teeth and becomes rigid." Sounds like a
revelation of Muhammad, but so I asked
your disciples to cast it out, and they
were not able to. He continues, "And he
answered them," Oh faithless generation,
how long am I to be with you? How long
am I to bear with you? Bring him to me.
And they brought the boy to him. And
when the spirit saw him, immediately it
convulsed the boy, and he fell on the
ground and rolled about foaming at the
mouth. And Jesus asked his father, "How
long has this been happening to him?"
And he said, "From childhood." and it
has often cast him into fire and into
water to destroy him. But if you can do
anything, have compassion on us and help
us." And Jesus said to him, "If you
can," he like, "What? You tripping? If
you can," he says, "All things are
possible for one who believes."
Immediately the father of the child
cried out and said, "I believe. Help my
unbelief." And when Jesus saw that a
crowd came running together, he rebuked
the unclean spirit, saying to it, "You
mute and deaf spirit, I command you,
come out of him, and never enter him
again." And after crying and compulsing
him terribly, it came out, and the boy
was like a corpse, so that most of them
thought uh said, "He is dead." But Jesus
took him by the hand and lifted him up,
and he arose. And when he had entered
the house, his disciples asked him
privately, why could we not cast him
out? said this kind cannot cannot be
driven out by anything but prayer. So
here notice the father's reaction. The
father believes right? Immediately the
father of the child cried out and said
verse 24 I believe but help my unbelief.
So he has he has belief. He believes him
but there's some unbelief. There's a
there's a level of unbelief that he has.
Now Jesus doesn't turn him away because
of this level of this, you know, little
thing of unbelief that he has. But he he
obliges him. He he answers him because
he has faith even as small as a mustard
seed. Christ says, "That's all you
need." He has belief and confesses,
"Lord, I believe, but help my unbelief."
And that's where that's what I'm kind of
hearing with you is that you believe.
Clearly, you believe, but you also have
an unbelief, like a little thing of
unbelief within you. Ask him to help you
with that. Ask him, "Help my unbelief."
Now in doing this bro this doesn't mean
that you don't accept him as your Lord
because the father here does. The father
of the child believes in Jesus. He
believes in Jesus and runs to him. You
do the same. Do the same. Accept him as
your Lord. Believe in him and ask him
because this is a relationship that we
have. It's a relationship and it's a
process. Like he builds us and he molds
us and forms us into more and more his
image into perfection until we reach
perfection. So, we're not going to be
starting off just 100%, you know, you
know, glory and super faith. That's not
that's not all of us. That's not all of
us. But we accept him and trust in him.
We put all our faith in him. Put all our
trust in him. And he helps our unbelief
along the way. So, that's what I would
suggest that that you do. Run to the
Lord. Don't wait. You don't have to wait
until you have every single uncertainty
answered. You know what I'm saying?
um before you give your life to him. You
know what I'm saying? Yeah, absolutely.
Thank you. Yeah, it is it is it is it is
true. And yeah, and what makes me sad
and what actually makes me Yeah. fear in
me is like I think sometimes I'm I'm so
corrupted from the Islamic way of
living. I can't maybe find the faith and
the love which you guys have that you
can sell, hey, I'm absolutely 100% sure
and this is Yeah. And this is this is
actually a big question mark or it's the
big fear in me and um thank you for that
part and it's absolutely makes sense.
Yeah, I totally agree and 100% bro allow
the Holy Spirit to work in you man.
That's all you got to do. Trust that
trust that the Lord is going to help
your unbelief. Trust him. Trust that he
will do it. But say yes. Tell him I tell
I believe you are my Lord. I believe
that you are God. I believe that you are
my savior. You died for my sins. You
rose on the third day. I believe this,
Lord, and I confess my sins to you, and
I confess my belief in you from my
heart, but help my unbelief as well.
Help me in the areas that I that I don't
believe. Help encourage me and bring
certainty in these areas, Lord, as I
give my life to you. And he'll do it. He
will not forsake you. That's a
guarantee. Amen. Thank you, brother. Of
course. Thank you for your words. Yep.
Yep. I'm any like I said the last guest
I'm here whenever um whenever you want
to make that decision. If you want to do
that on your own in your own time if you
need more time of course you know cuz it
has to be sincere and on your own time
from your own heart. So you want to do
that later by all means do that later.
If you want to do it now and say that
prayer for God to help your unbelief I'm
here for it now as well. So it's up to
you my brother what you want to do what
whatever your mind is brother. Brother,
I would say um we will talk again. Amen.
Um because I have to think about it
about what you said and and and I say it
again and Jesus is Lord. Amen. I think
he's resurrected. He came back and he is
there. It is it is and and actually what
was fascinated me the most is um that
you can talk to Jesus. He is there. He
was human and he's he's a kind of
person. He's God too. And it in Islam it
wasn't possible. It's not possible.
Maybe this is kind of my shyness what I
have in me and that's what the big fight
is in me it's going. Yeah. So he see
he's someone I can reach to and
yeah completely unlike Allah completely
unlike the fab the Issa fabrication that
the Quran gives you a picture of Jesus
is real and he's alive. It's you you can
have an actual true relationship and
communion and fellowship with our Lord.
That's what he offers. He's not some
absent deity that demands, you know, uh,
you know, religious prayers that you got
to recite in a foreign language and
whatnot. Yeah.
Right. Yeah. Exactly. Thank you very
much. I don't want to Yeah. hold you too
long and I'm here. I'm listening to you
and then when I'm ready, I I will I will
do that with you. I'm I'm pretty I'm
convinced with that. Thank you. Praise
God. I'm here anytime, Akan. I I'll
remember you, man. Yeah. Thank you very
much, brother.
God bless you, brother. You too, Ma. How
you doing? What's up, Avery? What's up,
man? What's up? So, uh, my topic is that
is Jesus the eternal eternal everlasting
God? Say it again. I'm sorry. Is Jesus
the eternal everlasting God? Yes. Uh,
what makes you think that like your
belief is like 100% on that? He says it.
He says that he's the first and the
last. And uh is that like is that like
you know a journey to learn that or what
do you mean like is it like so are you
asking how did I come to that
conclusion? Yeah that's yeah so just by
you know just reading the gospel reading
what Jesus says about himself. He claims
to be the everlasting God. He claims to
be the first and the last the alpha and
the omega the beginning and the end. He
claims to be the resurrection and the
life. He claims to be the judge on
judgment day. He claims to have come
down from heaven, right? He claims to
be, you know, the Bible says that he is
the word of God that created all things.
So, we see that through the gospel when
we're reading and studying what Jesus
says and also what the apostles say
through the Holy Spirit through their
writings, we see that Jesus along with
the father and the holy spirit are the
everlasting God. Yeah. Uh pretty funny
cuz uh you know, I was uh reading about
Jesus right now. I was thinking about
him and then uh some dude with a similar
you know situation came up to your live
and started talking about you know
similar issues that I have and Mhm. I
was like I was just thinking in my mind
wow this timing is insane. Timing is
crazy. The timing is crazy. You you grew
up in a Muslim home? Oh yeah. Oh man.
You you sure it's cool for you to be on
camera right now? You're you're safe.
You're good. Uh yeah. Okay. That's good.
you know, just pray for me, you know.
Yeah, definitely will. But have you read
the Have you read the gospel before or
what? Like what's what's Tell me tell me
a little bit about yourself where you're
at right now. So, you know, I've seen
signs and I've been getting signs and
you know, uh, you know, I feel like it's
a journey, but at the point I'm at right
now is that I just someone gave me the
Bible, my coach. Oh, yeah. Yeah. my he
gave me, you know, the his Bible and I
have it with me, but I haven't really
opened my heart to it and read it. So,
that's the point I'm at right now and uh
yeah, that's pretty much where I'm at,
but there's more to it. It's very It's a
very complex testimony, I think.
Do you So, uh have you like um do you
think that maybe you've experienced
Jesus a bit that you've come and had
some type of encounter? Yeah, for sure.
That's deep, man. Yeah. And so what what
has what has your I guess your response
been since your encounter this
experience? What has happened? What or
how have you responded? Like how have
you been moving ever since? Um you know
it's it's very hard um to you know be
with my family and stuff. Yeah. And you
know, it's like, you know, we're not all
perfect. And you know, I think we do
need something like someone like Jesus
to forgive us. Amen. And you know, it's
like it's like if you don't have someone
that takes your blames away, it's going
to be hard on the person who's doing the
sins. So that's, you know, that's why I
always gravitate. And every time I watch
your live or something, I see that and
it's like in my heart, you know, but
it's, you know, hard to commit to it
because, you know, the background I'm
coming from and stuff. Yep. So, you
know, it's it's very complex, very
complex situation, very complex
testimony, I think. So, yeah, hopefully
in the future, you know, it it gets
easier, you know. Oh, brother. Trust me,
the the second the more that you the
more that you open yourself up o up to
Christ, the more that you obey his voice
and you follow his pool, the the lighter
the burden becomes because he let me
just let me show you what he says here,
bro. Oh my goodness. Let me show you
what he says. The the the Holy Spirit is
really bringing you guys to the stream.
It's not it's not a coincidence, dude,
that all of you guys are coming to the
stream with similar experiences and have
experienced Christ and you know it's and
I think um are being encouraged by each
other to even come and share. But let me
just show you what he says here, man.
This is what he says. And this is
Matthewap 11. And this is also what I'm
going to tell you to read when we get
done cuz if you have a you said your
coach gave you your Bible. So I would
read read Matthew and I'm going to show
you why. Red letters is Jesus speaking.
says, "All things have been handed over
to me by my father. No one knows the son
except the father and no one knows the
father except the son and anyone to whom
the son chooses to reveal it." And so in
this time you have been getting
experience where Christ is choosing to
reveal himself and the father to you and
has been on your heart. And then he says
this, "Come to me all who labor and are
heavy laden and I will give you rest.
Take my yoke upon you and learn from me
for I am gentle and lowly in heart and
you will find rest for your souls. For
my yoke is easy and my burden is light.
So what Christ here just promised and
guarantees is that you come to him, he
will take care of the rest.
Yeah. I'm laughing cuz it's like the
signs are just so obvious. Yeah. Yep.
I'm telling you, he literally speaks and
this is his word. He speaks to us. He's
spoken to you already. He has spoken to
you already and he's brought you to this
stream really just as a confirmation.
I'm not I'm not saying anything new or
anything. All of this is just a
confirmation, brother. That's it. And so
really, Christ is just calling you to
obey his voice. Obey. Come to him and
he'll do the he'll do the rest. whatever
the like the like the like Hakan the
previous guest that he you know he
believed but had this little little
thing little trinket of unbelief and
that's okay because you can you can say
I believe Lord help me where I
disbelieve help my unbelief he'll take
care of it you know what I'm saying so
that's his guarantee to us that's his
promise and so as you say yes and you
follow Christ you accept him as your
Lord you go to him don't work it out by
yourself or go to him He will do the
rest, bro. Thank you. Yep. 100%. 100%.
So, you said it's been on your heart,
man. For sure. Yeah. The one thing
though is that it's um it's the claims
of my religion that, you know, it's like
a divert. It's like it's like kind of,
you know, it's you know, Muslims believe
it's so 100% on it and it it, you know,
for people around it, it's like, you
know, it's like instilled in them. Yeah.
And so it's it's kind of hard getting
past that, but I feel like Christ is
guiding me and uh you know, letting me
know who's the the true living God.
Yeah. Who like why I need him, you know.
Yep. And I feel like I've experienced
that why we all need his forgiveness.
Yeah. Amen. And uh it's kind of obvious,
but because in Islam there's like, you
know, if you're not perfect, then it's
like you're going to you're going to
take all the blame. We're going to be
doomed.
You're doomed. And actually, it's it's
it's it's actually the same in
Christianity, bro. If you're not
perfect, you're doomed. Unfortunately,
we can't be perfect. So, Christ came and
was perfect for us. That's the message
of the gospel is that God's standard is
perfection, but we fall short of that
standard. So, he came himself to work
out that perfection for us. So that in
him it's his righteousness that is
applied to us now. Yeah. For those of us
who believe that's the gospel in Islam
you don't have that. You don't have a
savior but you need one. Yeah. So yeah.
Yeah. I feel the the power in Jesus
absorbing your sins. Yeah. There's
definitely a power there for sure. Oh
yeah. 100%. 100%. It's unlike any other.
And uh for him to do that he has to have
all power in order to be able to absorb
people's sins. Right. Imagine absorbing
the sins of the world. In order to do
that, you have to have all power. Yeah.
Gotta be unbeatable. So, man, you just
got you just got to say yes, man. You
believe already, dog. You believe
already. So, I'll tell you this. I'll
tell you this, just like I told the last
guest, man, cuz it's important. Each and
every one of you guys have experienced
Christ. All of you. One of you fully
said yes so far. Two of you have con,
you know, expressed your belief and
expressed the process that you're in.
You're in a very delicate process. You
know, you're in a very delicate process.
I say, choose today who you serve. Okay?
Take your time, pray, spend time in
prayer, and read the Bible. I'll tell
you, read the book of Matthew. Start
there. Read the book of Matthew. Get to
know Jesus. Get to know the Lord and his
words. Get familiar with his voice and
his words. Okay? And when you're ready,
hopefully it's much sooner than later,
but when you're ready and it's on your
heart, confess him as your Lord. Confess
your sins to him. Confess him as your
Lord. Announce that you believe in him
and that you believe that he died for
your sins and you trust in him alone for
your salvation. Confess that to him and
the moment you do that, you're a brother
in Christ. You're saved. Okay. Yeah. Can
you do one prayer for me before I go? I
I'll leave after the prayer. Yeah. Just
any prayer you want. Whatever you think
is good for me. I got you, bro. I got
you. So, my father in heaven, we thank
you. We thank you for the grace of your
son. We thank you for the power of your
holy spirit. We thank you Lord for
bringing our friend Musa here. We thank
you for calling him. We thank you for
drawing him. And Lord, we just ask not
just him but those around him and his
family and his friends that the light of
Christ reflects off of him and gets his
friends and family curious about your
love and your truth. Lord, I ask that
you encourage Musa. Give him power and
faith to confess that you, Lord, are the
only savior. That father, you sent your
son into the world to die for his sins.
And you rose again in power, defeating
death, rose again on the third day. And
that it's in him alone. It's in you
alone that we find our salvation. Lord,
continue to draw on him. Give him
wisdom. Give him courage. Give him
power. Give him understanding, Lord. and
most of all give him faith to follow you
in Jesus name we pray. In the name of
the father, son, and holy spirit we
pray. Amen. Amen. Thank you for that. Of
course, brother. God bless you, man. I
can't wait to see I hope we talk again,
bro. I can't wait to see you again, man.
All right. All right. All right. Peace,
man. Peace. Hey, B. What's up? So, I had
a question for you, right? Sure. Go
ahead. So, uh, do Christians believe in
the Torah and the Tanakh? Right. 100%.
Right. So why did when Jesus came,
right? Why did the Jews not believe in
him? Well, you have the heart of the
people. Um they had their own desires
and um Jesus was calling them out. He's
calling them out for their sin, for
their hypocrisy, and they did not like
that and rejected that. You see that?
That's pretty consistent with the
prophets. You know, the prophets come,
they warn the Israelites of their
rebellion and what God's going to do if
they continue to rebel in sin. and they
continue to rebel. It's crazy. So, uh I
also like looked up what the Messiah
would would like the description of the
Messiah according to the to the Tanakh
and of the Torah, right? Yeah. And it
said that it doesn't match up with
Jesus. Who who said that? Well, she
apparently for real. Oh, I have no one
to ask. Avery, that's why I'm here. You
You do have someone to add. Matter of
fact, hold on a second. I think Let me
get it. Let me give me one second. One
second. I'm going to call a Jew. Is that
okay? Yeah, that's okay. Let me call a
Jew real quick. Hopefully he answers.
Hopefully he's not too good to not
answer. He's a rabbi. Is Radar live
right now, guys? I hope he's not live.
Your call has been forwarded. Wow.
Unfortunate. That's great. By the way,
every this is this is not an attack on
Christianity or anything, right? It's
genuine. I know. Last time I remember
talking to you. You're you know, I I
trust that you have a good intent. Thank
you so much, wife. I trust that you got
good intentions. You ask good questions.
You're reasonable. So, you you're all
good. Um but okay. So, I I'll do it
myself then. You know, I tried to call I
tried to call Radar and uh you know, he
didn't want to answer me. You know, he's
too good. We got Jason with the super
chat. He says, "Ironically, when Jesus
came, it was only Jews who believed in
him because of the Torah ant." That's
right. So, you have this split where
Jews disbelieve in Jesus, but then you
have Jews who do believe in Jesus
because of the scriptures. So, for
example, let's look at a few let's look
at a few things. Um, let's see. We'll do
Isaiah
7:14. We'll do Isaiah. We'll do um
Isaiah 53rd. We'll do Psalm 22. We'll do
Micah 5:2. All right. So, let's bring up
some scriptures, man, and see what the
fuss is all about. All right. So, we got
Isaiah 7:14 here. It says, "Therefore,
the Lord himself will give you a sign.
Behold, the virgin shall conceive and
bear a son, and shall call his name
Emmanuel. Now, Emanuel in the Hebrew
means God. That's right. You got it. All
right. So, so far we see in Isaiah gives
this prophecy of a virgin giving birth.
Yeah, that's the first time. Does that
match anybody else in history? Jesus.
That's it. Jesus. Let's keep going.
Let's see how many of these we can find.
I'll We'll do 53 uh last cuz that's my
favorite one. Psalm 22 is my second
favorite. We'll do that after two. Let's
do Micah 5:2. Do you do you know where
Jesus was born? Jerusalem or Nazareth,
right? Nazareth. So he he grew up in
Nazareth. But he wasn't born in
Nazareth. He was actually born in
Bethlehem. Bethlehem. Where is that?
That's in it's in Judea. It's in Judea.
It's not Jerusalem. Jerusalem is like a
city. Jerusalem in the west. Mhm. So you
have Bethlehem. Now this is what Micah
5:2 says. It says, "But you, oh
Bethlehem Epheretha, who are too little
to be among the clans of Judah, from you
shall come forth for me one who is to be
ruler in Israel, whose coming forth is
from old, from ancient days." So from
Bethlehem is going to come the one who's
supposed to be the ruler of Israel.
That's the Messiah, right? I mean,
that's the description that they give,
right? Yep. That's the description that
they give. He's the ruler in Israel.
He's going to rule on David's throne
when he comes back and all that kind of
stuff. So, and we have Jesus who's
literally born in Bethlehem. Bethlehem.
Yeah, that's right. Now, let me think of
uh any other small ones that I could
think of before we get to the main ones.
Before I get to my favorite ones,
there's some there's some little ones.
Let's see here. Okay, he's supposed to
be a descendant of David. Okay, a
descendant of David. Let's go to Let's
Let's add here. Let's do Do you know who
who David's father is? David's father
was I have no clue. No, no clue. His
name is Jesse. David's father prophet.
No, he wasn't a prophet. Wasn't a
prophet. A regular guy. Good guy. Solid
solid guy. Um he had uh a bunch of sons
and David was the youngest. Okay. And so
is this it? Yes. So here it is. This is
Isaiah 11. It says, "There shall come
forth a chute from the stump of Jesse."
That means like a generation of Jesse.
Mhm. And a branch from his roots shall
bear fruit. So it's saying that's that
there's going to come someone from the
line of Jesse, from the stump of Jesse,
from his roots. Right? So this is
David's line specifically. Okay. And it
says, "And the spirit of the Lord shall
rest upon him." So whoever this person
is, the spirit of the Lord is going to
come and rest upon him. The spirit of
wisdom and understanding, the spirit of
counsel and might, the spirit of the
knowledge and the fear of the Lord, and
his delight. All four of them are one.
Yeah. All Yeah. All of these are the
spirit of the Lord. These are just
different qualities of the spirit.
Descriptions of them. Yeah. Yeah.
Exactly. Exactly. You got it. So he
says, "And his delight shall be in the
fear of the Lord." Like he's going to
respect God. He's going to rever him.
Right. He shall not judge by what he
sees with his eyes, or decide disputes
by what his ears hear, but with
righteousness he shall judge the poor,
and decide with equity for the meek of
the earth. And he shall strike the earth
with the rod with the rod of his mouth,
not with a sword, but with what he says,
with his speech. And with the breath of
his lips, he shall kill the wicked. By
his words alone is going to convict the
wicked. is going to convict them either
to turn and be right or condemn them.
Okay? Righteousness shall be the belt of
his waist and faithfulness the belt of
his loins. Now, who does this sound like
that's a descendant of Jesse, a
descendant of David in his line and
generation who the spirit rests upon and
he has fear of the Lord just perfect his
counsel, his wisdom unlike any other.
And he doesn't bring a sword. He doesn't
fight, you know, or nothing like that.
But he just fights with his words. His
words are enough to convict the wicked.
So, one question. So, is is uh Jesus,
right, related to David? Yes. Yes. He's
a descendant of David. Okay. I never
knew that. Yeah. I mean, that's that's
that's one of the key that's one of the
key points, the key factors of the
Messiah. The Messiah has to be a
descendant of David. He has to be in his
line. And so that's what makes, you
know, that's another thing for Jesus is
that he's a descendant of David of the
tribe of Judah. Okay, here's another
example of this. Let's go. Let's erase
Isaiah 11. Let's put Jeremiah 23.
Jeremiah 23. Look, we're going. This is
a good Bible study we're having. Okay,
Jeremiah 23. All right, here it is.
Verse 5 and 6. Okay, it says in verse 5,
"Behold, the days are coming, declares
the Lord, when I will raise up for David
a righteous branch, and he shall reign
as king and deal wisely and shall
execute justice and righteousness in the
land. In his days, Judah will be saved,
and Israel will dwell securely. And this
is the name by which he will be called.
The Lord is our righteousness." So
again, this is another prophecy of the
Messiah, the one who's going to rule in
Israel, who's going to bring justice and
righteousness, and he has to be a branch
of David. He has to be a root of David,
right? All of this Jesus matches. All of
this Jesus matches. He brought salvation
to Judah, died for their sin. Now, let
me show you how. Let's get to now the
salvation. What about this part? This is
Psalm 22, verse one. My God, my God, why
have you forsaken me? Sound familiar? My
God, my God, why have you forsaken me?
That don't sound familiar? No, it
doesn't. Oh, come on, man. Am I supposed
to remember it? Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
This is one of Muslims love to bring
this up. Not not Psalm particularly, but
when Jesus says this. Hold on. Let me
show you, bro. Let me show you. Let me
show you. Hold on. Let me bring it up.
At Jesus's crucifixion, when he's on the
cross, when he's on the cross, this is
what he yells out. This is going to be
Matthew 27, starting at verse 45. Now
from the sixth hour there was darkness
over all the land until the 9inth hour.
And about the 9inth hour Jesus cried out
with a loud voice saying, "Eli, Eli,
lama," that is, "My God, my God, why
have you forsaken me?" So Jesus here,
while he's on the cross, quotes Psalm
22, the first verse. Now, why in the
world do you think is Jesus crying this
out on the cross? You think it's just
like, oh my goodness, he's just going
through some bad things. Or is it a
bigger purpose here? And let me show you
why. Let me show you what it is. Shall
we keep reading? You with me? Yeah.
Yeah. All right. Psalm 22. So this is
what Jesus quoted on the cross. My God,
my God, why have you forsaken me? Why
are you so far from saving me from the
words of my groaning? Oh my God, I cry
by day, but you do not answer. And by
night, but I find no rest. Yet you are
wholly enthroned on the praises of
Israel. In you, in you our fathers
trusted, they trusted and you delivered
them. To you they cried and were
rescued. And you they trusted and you
and they were not put to shame. But I am
a worm and not a man. Scorned by mankind
and despised by the people. All who see
me mock me. They make mouths at me. They
wag their heads. He trusts in the Lord.
Let him deliver him. Let him rescue him
for he delights in him. You see how
they're mocking him? Yeah. This is
similarly to what we see on the cross
with Jesus. They're mocking. Uhhuh. Yep.
They're mocking him, saying, "You're
you're the son of God. Come down. Save
yourself. You was able to save others.
Save him." That's what they're doing.
The same thing. Let's continue. Yet you
are he who took me from the womb. You
made me trust you at my mother's breast.
On you I was cast from my on you was I
cast from my birth and from my mother's
womb you have been my God. Be not far
from me for trouble is near and there is
none to help. Many bulls encompass me.
Strong bulls of Bashan surround me. They
open wide their mouths at me like a
ravening and roaring lion. I am poured
out like water and all my bones are out
of joint. Sounds like getting Yes,
exactly. My heart is like wax. It is
melted within my breast. Meaning it's
hard for him to breathe. It's It's heavy
breathing. And that's what happens when
your arms are stretched out and your
weight you can't breathe. It's hard to
breathe. My strength is dried up like a
potshirt. And my tongue sticks to my
jaw. He's thirsty. You lay me in the
dust of death. For dogs encompass me. A
company of evildoers encircles me. My
favorite part. They have pierced my
hands and my feet. I can count all my
bones. They stare and gloat over me.
They divide my garments among them. And
for my clothing they cast lots. And this
is exactly what happened with Jesus. The
Roman soldiers took his clothes and they
gambled over him. They sure did. Let me
show you this. John chapter 19. We're
going to scroll down to around the uh
here it is, verse 23 and 24. When the
soldiers had crucified Jesus, they took
his garments and divided them into four
parts, one part for each soldier, also
his tunic. But the tunic was seamless,
woven in one piece from top to bottom.
So they said to each other, "Let's not
tear it, but cast lots for it to see
whose it shall be." This was to fulfill
the scripture which says, "They divided
my garments among them, and for my
clothing they cast lots." So the
soldiers did these things. What is Chad
GBT talking about that is clueless? Then
it's crazy. What What is going on here,
man? Are you kidding me? It literally
talks about him having his hands and
feet pierced. What are they talking
about? You have to literally be blind
and be biased and possibly downright
stupid to reject that the Old Testament
contains uh prophecies about Jesus, him
being the Messiah, and his descriptions.
You got to be blind um and downright
stupid, unfortunately. Want to see my
favorite one? Yeah. Is there more? Oh,
bro. This I I'm only do I'm only doing
this for the sake of time. Like I'm
showing you like short stuff. Like
there's there's so many prophecies about
Jesus. I can't deny this like so far
like Yeah. Hundreds of them, bro. And
and I'm not talking about, oh, we got to
interpret them and oh, you know, you
know, like they're up in the air.
There's great. No, I'm talking about
plain explicit description. It can't be
nobody else other than Jesus or else
you're out of your freaking mind. You
get what I'm saying? This is what I'm
showing you. There's hundreds of them,
but I'm just, you know, for the sake of
time in the stream, I I can only show a
few. So, but there's so much more, bro.
Um, but let me show you my favorite one.
My favorite one is this one. Isaiah 53.
This is my favorite one. So, this is Oh,
sorry. Let me go ahead and share this.
So, it starts off like this. Who has
believed what he has heard from us? And
to whom has the arm of the Lord been
revealed? For he grew up before him like
a young plant and like a root out of dry
ground. He had no form or majesty that
we should look at him and no beauty that
we should desire. He was despised and
rejected by men, a man of sorrows and
acquainted with grief. And as one from
whom men hide their faces, he was
despised and we esteemed him not. We
didn't think anything special about him.
Right? And we despised him. We rejected
him. Watch what it says. Verse four.
Surely he has borne our griefs and
carried our sorrows. Yet we esteemed him
stricken, smitten by God, and afflicted.
But he was pierced for our
transgressions. He was crushed for our
iniquities. Upon him was the
chastisement that brought us peace, the
punishment. And with his wounds, we are
healed. All we like sheep have gone
astray. We have turned everyone to his
own way. And the Lord has laid on him
the iniquity of us all. God placed all
of our sins on this one person. It
continues, bro. It gets better if you
think this is something. It gets better.
Trust me. He was oppressed and he was
afflicted yet he opened not his mouth.
Like a lamb that is led to the slaughter
and like a sheep that before its sheer
is silent. So he opened not his mouth.
Meaning when he he was faced with his
oppressors, he didn't fight back. He
didn't resist. He went willingly. When
they was sitting there asking him
questions, he didn't fight the
accusations. He didn't answer their
questions. He let them slap him, spit on
him, beat him. He didn't fight back. No,
he suffered a lot. Yes. Yes, he did.
Yes, he did. All for us, bro. All for
us. And this is why this is not
something to take lightly. Like you see
us Christians and we we have songs to
Jesus. We praise Jesus because this is
what he did for us. And this isn't even
really describing everything. Like this
is just giving us a simple picture. It's
it's actually worse than this in
reality, man. Worse than this. But
imagine that, man. being innocent, being
just and holy, and all you you love
these people, and you've come for these
people, and they're humiliating you,
spitting on you, punching you,
blaspheming you. Imagine that. And he's
just sitting there taking it for a
purpose. So, I won't take up much of
your time, Avery. I think you you've
given me enough proof. Oh, this is
enough. This is good. I I'll be
completely honest, right? When when I
first joined, like I think two days ago,
right? I've never been on your stream
before, right? Yeah. Yeah. I was
hardcore into my belief, right? I was
like unshaken, right? Now I can say that
for sure there are doubts in my hair,
like my heart, right? Like I can I
cannot deny this. Yeah. Logically, I
cannot deny this. Yeah. 100%. I like to
take everything with logic. Like your
name, she logic, right? That's right.
That's right, baby. I like to take
everything with logic. Right. So far,
everything you've said, I cannot deny
it. Right. Yeah. So, I won't be taking
up much of your time. I need to read up
more on this. Right. So, I had one
question that I had with a Catholic
friend of mine, right? Yeah. So, it's
it's a bit of a personal question,
right? I was very close with my grandma,
but unfortunately, she passed away,
right? Like a couple of years ago. Yeah.
And she was a Muslim, right?
And she died a Muslim, right? Yeah. I
mean, I know we can't judge, we can't
say who's going to heaven or to hell.
Only God can do that. But would she be
going to heaven if she lived a good
life? Well, this the the hard truth
about this, bro, is that um the Bible
shows that like none of us are good. And
what it means by that is that we've all
fallen short of sin. We've all sinned
against God, right? So, be God's
standard is perfection. And if we fall
short of his standard, we are guilty.
All of us. We lied one time. I'm guilty.
I have to face my sin on judgment day.
You know, even if I never did it again,
I have to face my sin. This is why we
need the savior. And so without without
Jesus without Jesus we don't have a
savior for we have to face God for our
sins ourself. Jesus without Jesus is the
one who comes and he puts his
righteousness upon us for those who
believe and accept what he did for us.
You know so uh unfortunately the truth
is if she died rejecting Jesus and she
doesn't have a savior on that day. You
know what I'm saying? So so she's on her
own pretty much. She's on her own. But
will her actions speak for her? They
can't. They can't because it's it's
impossible. You It's It's almost like if
um if if I try like let's say I I I um I
break the law a few times in my life,
you know? I break the law a few times in
my life. Let's say I've stolen, you
know, from a bank. I robbed a bank
before and you know um I've I've robbed
a couple times, right? But I've also fed
the poor. I've, you know, saved um kids
from burning buildings. Um you know,
I've done some good things in my life.
But I got caught for robbing the bank,
you know. And I tell the judge, "Yes,
judge, you know that that you got you
got me red-handed. That's me. I I did
rob the bank. And yes, I actually have a
history where I've robbed the bank a few
times, you know, but I've saved people
from burning buildings. I've offered
medicine to sick people. I've visited
people in their sick beds and taken care
of some orphans. What, you know, I
should still rob the bank." Exactly. And
so with that, even with the earthly
judge being that just, God is even more
just and holy. He cannot be bribed with
our good works. And that's that's what
the message of the gospel. That's why we
absolutely need a savior. We can't do it
on our own. Despite him being most
merciful and most loving. Well, at the
same time, he's he doesn't sacrifice
like his he doesn't eliminate his
justice. He he can't sweep sin under the
rug and be merciful. Yes, but now he's
lacking justice. You know what I'm
saying? And so this is why Christ had to
come because now all the justice is
being displayed on Christ. He took the
punishment for us so that when we face
God on that day, we don't have cuz we
can't. There's nothing I can do. Christ
did it for me, you know. Um at the end
of the day, God I I can only give what
what Jesus said. And um and God knows,
man. I don't know if if she experienced
Christ or whatever. That's one of the
the reasons why it's it's hard for a lot
of people to switch over from Islam to
Christianity, right? Because if you do
that, you basically just say to everyone
you've loved that that has died around
you that was Muslim, you basically
accept that they're going to hell. And
it can be a very hard decision. It's
tough, man. It's tough. It's I I
couldn't imagine that. I mean, I I I
mean, I got family members who have
passed away who I know, you know, they
they rejected Christ and they died
rejecting Christ. You deal with that.
It's not for me to deal with. That's the
thing. It's it's it's up to God. That's
that's how I I loved them. Um and but
that's not for me to worry about. It's
not it's not my place. You get what I'm
saying? It's like we we would drive
ourselves crazy worrying about other
people's souls to that extent. Like
we'll drive ourselves crazy. And so I
just I give it over to God, man. I give
it over to God. I know what he said in
his word. I know what his truth is. And
I know the unfortunate end to die
without him. I just leave it over I
leave it to God. I can't I can't destroy
my mind worrying about that stuff. It's
hard to deal with. Yeah. Well, thank you
for your time, Avery. Happy Holy Week.
Do we say that? Yeah. Yeah, you can say
that. Happy Holy Week. Thank you, man.
Thank you for your time. And I'm going
to let someone talk. Wait. B. Yeah.
Please don't don't let it be too long
that I see you again, man. Yeah, for
sure. I'm going to be I'm going to be
showing up again. Yeah. Good. Keep
coming. Keep coming. Thank you for your
time, baby. All right. and God bless
you, bro.